all right and we are live welcome to the
iron Lords podcast episode number 47 and
it's another glorious Sunday and we are
back at the roundtable on the Lord's Day
we've got a very special guest combat
sports talk the reign of booty due to
announcement speculation and Nintendo
liable to discuss so we're gonna get
right into it I want to introduce the
Lord who in my opinion offers some of
the most balanced and honest
perspectives in all of these YouTube
streets this Lord consistently provides
high quality content with a smooth
delivery classic retro feel but more
importantly makes us focus on what
really matters having fun and enjoying
these great games introducing mr. Luke
chess radio himself and a member of our
DX TSP 60 frames and the GOG podcasts
the coolest level had a gamer fellow MMA
fan and the Lord who always challenges
everyone to think for themselves making
his debut into the realm of the Lord's
mom made Lord Jay Fonzarelli how you
doing sir
what's up I got a stage but that is the
best intro I've ever had so I appreciate
that man it's it's Sunday this is the
same day my podcast drops as well this
is a great time to be on iron Lords
podcast I can't wait to talk about these
fights and whatever other topics you got
going on it's gonna be it's gonna be a
blast guys absolutely huge fan of yours
you're a lot at what you do so when you
come to the I love podcast we got to
roll out the red carpet for you show you
that proper respect man huge fan glad to
have you all bet likewise man likewise
and of course we have those usual
suspects at the round table we're down
to Lords today the co-host with the
Como's he may be joining us in progress
work is holding him hostage but we still
might get some Lord
action and um I want to give a shout out
salute to a lord soft lady saw
condolences and please give their
thoughts and prayers to their family
right now there's they have a loss in
the family and he's out the MPR you know
ten into ten in his needs
you know I know he's going through
because I've been through it myself and
actually have to go through it myself
when you're older you know you start
losing people make sure everybody keeps
law solved in their prayers and
hopefully we'll get them back so but of
course we still have the excess gave o
the Lord of combat sports whose
convictions experience Lord King we are
in here right now we're so in here right
now guys I know last night everybody
house was like ESPN it was I swear if I
had a bar people walking through it it
felt really good it would felt really
good the nachos is at the table I said I
don't need the chicken wings and stuff
like that cuz the Duff that definitely
would have been prevalent yesterday was
my son's birthday the king of the room
young prince is seven years old so he
was on his little prince wag yesterday
you know very eccentric with his stuff
had to go to gamestop and um he
definitely got a pop and he's smart
because he has all the systems I stuff
for the arm dis generation you know I
don't put him in a mix with this
generation this generation of
a generation behind ya he stays right
behind he's right behind me we had good
fun last night yes sir but he went
inside Game Stop yesterday and I told
him I said um yeah 60 bucks so he was
like HM now one kid would have been
stupid I said let me get this one game
he said daddy what are you do with the
Wii games not that we you with the Wii
games cuz we is poppin he ran over to
the Wii he was getting $7 games $3 games
2 dolla games he backed up slung he went
to the to the counter with like 7 joints
there we go I had enough money left over
to get some candy and get out of
spreading that gaming realness on the
ILP now telling you what you want to
hear but what you need to hear so before
we get into what the Lords of plan I
want to start off with know what
Fonzarelli his video game system history
what had him to being a member of some
of the top podcasts in the game as well
as creating that amazing loot chest
radio swell phones really let's start
from the beginning what was some of the
first gaming systems you had well if you
really want to start from the beginning
it all started in the arcades bro this
is one back to in like pong was still
you know the first console you know so
we didn't have nothing like that you
know and this started out matter of fact
in the Philippines because I used to
live down there as a baby until I was 7
years old so oh my first taste of the
arcades was actually down there and when
I came to the States
like you know we was all over that going
to this corner store and having I don't
know if people remember what corner
stores were like but we call them
bodegas in New York exactly and they
would have like this one machine in
there and
was a you know tabletop machine and well
it would pac-man and we would be in
there playing pacman and and all kinds
of stuff and then my uncle one day he
brought home the Atari 2600 oh and I'm
telling you I was hooked ever since we
had pac-man at home we couldn't believe
it you know and this one's going back to
82 so I I couldn't believe we actually
had you know the arcades in our house
yes that was just amazing to us at the
time and we were playing games like
adventure where you were a little square
a little dungeon and dude it was so
rudimentary but man for back then it
blew our minds you know and they're
damned peed and all these other games
pitfall and then we went through other
consoles too we had this one I believe
it was the Commodore 64 my brother had
we had the NES we had the ColecoVision
we had to Khalid go to dice yeah yeah so
I mean it just went on from there but my
favorite console of all time still still
remains the Dreamcast stick and we were
talking about it and I'm a huge
Dreamcast and also you know just talking
about like launch lineups and um you
know obviously we know right now the
switches is really popping and I think
more it's thing he kind of listed all of
like the Dreamcast launch titles anyone
when you actually see them listed I was
like wow he may have a point he may have
a play we go get Stig low for that show
do we continue look it's not just that -
it's not just all the games that they
had because they had some great games
but it was the console itself
it was so ahead of its time it had so
much going for it it had online
components it has the vmu you've never
seen anything like the vmu again and why
the [ __ ] not
oh sorry just get passionate about we
love it we love
I'm telling those VM yous are just they
were amazing remember when you were
sitting couch co-op or or you're sitting
there playing Madden against your buddy
on the cat Mews and pick your plays and
he wouldn't see what you were doing
because you know with the other consoles
it was all on the screen nowadays it's
still all on the screen when you're side
by side what happened to that man bring
that stuff back who cares about the
touchpad on the ps4 you know bring back
a screen bring back something you can
utilize on that thing mm-hmm
phenomenal so yeah baby class was so
ahead of its time I'm glad you made that
point about the V mu you know Lord King
on me he had it all and it was such a
cool thing because you had that screen
in your controller that would like you
said would man would have you would have
the plays listed it just added an extra
level of depth and looking how we jump
in it from our I didn't know him other
games that were kind of like separate
also on the vmsu war continued what I
did was with the sonic you was able to
take little arm a little eggs and mature
your little eggs with you and they pop
out and turn it's a little like
Tamagotchis that's what they're really
started from because the time of God she
was going crazy in Japan so Sega said
well let us capitalize on that the only
problem with the vmu was the battery
life was terrible and then they
exchanged the battery inside the back
that was a miscalculation on their part
but they were so far ahead at the times
when you know the online the Ethernet
and we we credit Microsoft with having
the first Ethernet no brother it was was
it like a 33 6 modem with the aliens
online because my mother will pick
shoutouts my mom's pick up the phone and
she ran inside the living room one day
with tears in her eyes because she
picked up the phone while I was playing
an online match I think it was like to
pay or something I don't know what I was
playing the boy the aliens here and it
would take
I'll never get another delivery with the
sheet over by hey no back in your
history you had you had you said Atari
you say Coleco you said a lot of classic
stuff in there much outside drinkin did
you did you I didn't have the Master
System
I had the NES at the time my buddy my
best friend had the Master System so we
go over each others house and play both
so any problem with that
that's like me looking but when the
Super Nintendo dropped in the Genesis I
had both and then I even bought that you
know that terrible Sega CD system don't
put your head down when you say that
okay that was very premium that Sega CD
was so premium I don't care how great me
our grains were okay here's the thing
about the Sega CD the only good thing
about it was the sound like yes put in a
game and I'd be like this looks kind of
the same like wow that sounds amazing
but I mean come on super shark it wasn't
like the turbo graphics 16 CD because I
had the PC engine dual CD and that you
know listen my my gaming is so extensive
is insane but and I was anything that
was cutting-edge I even had the jaguar
CD that's horrible the flip top there
with that the thing with it is they they
they had this one that dance dance Marky
Mark and the Funky Bunch oh my god how
to make a video that game was so huge I
think it's so like a million and when
they saw that the FMV full motion video
creig's went left sua shocked and all
that other stuff and uh was a Sherlock
Holmes Sarah calls blue carnitas mother
away yes I like Sherlock Holmes I
actually like that game it's like what
you say lawful and it was like it didn't
I was disappointed it didn't improve the
graphs but for the sound and the voice
acting all the the frills that it gave
the game yes it definitely amplified
things but I was kind of hoping that it
was a larger kind of deal you know there
is their Lord addict yeah brother
Gobbo we didn't think we'd get you today
or not actually a mandatory overtime
today but I switch it for another day
that we're reminiscing about more fons
game yes we have some good old oh gee
Lord talk right now so you could pay
attention so I could have been like five
ten for not being alive during this you
know you know what that is true and that
is my bad I gotta take you down memory
lane so what I'm gonna do when we go to
pax right what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
bring my Neo Geo I'm gonna bring my uh
my Genesis switch oh I gotta say I gotta
say Neo Geo was one of those consoles I
could never afford as a kid alright my
parents would never buy me that but I
remember one time a buddy of mine rented
it back in the day you'd be able to rent
these consoles from different
mom-and-pop shops and he rented it and
we couldn't believe he had basically Neo
Geo arcade in his house and we were just
playing those games man
the great system but yeah it was one of
those that I wish I could have afforded
back then for sure listen when you have
someone like a premium Lord King we went
to his house to to make sure he had all
the but you know what it was like when
you purchased it though if it was born
by size because when they said 512 megs
it was all in there it won't really know
about compression no not at all it was
giant they were actually like Lou
laptops for me I think you got you're
very diversified so I'm very impressed
with that now as far as now as far as
like deeming franchises like give me
your top 5 gaming franchise or top 5
games of all time I usually limited to
tell people franchises just to kind of
give them a little bit more broad
choices franchises well I'll give you
I'll give you games I'll give you one
one of the games that sticks out in my
mind is I gotta go to a halo one combat
Evolved and that was one of my favorite
gaming moments when I beat that same
classic I just felt that that was the
the first shooter that I went through
that I really was impressed with all the
way oh absolutely
Final Fantasy 7 is another one Lord
addicts ears a pircuit right now yeah I
really like that one a lot
Masek man this is kind of hard you know
you know I can't right now I can't give
you three other games right first you
attempt that many so now I will tell you
what franchise I wish to see come back
ok and that is of course legacy of kain
I'll spot you touching a spot we'll be
right
of getting emotional because they have
so many good games man his soul reaver
just blew me away on the dream you had
man like bring it back already we need a
new game in this series vampire game is
coming is trying to pick up the torch
from the arm old developers or some I
think the old writers from the Legacy of
Kain series it's a PC game right now
called vampire and it's RPG action slash
RPG and I saw it at e3 at the PC section
it looks and say I know exactly because
legacy had a real emotional bond for me
because I'm one of the rear rail ones
that like I like the first legacy of
kain when it was king when it was other
games I guess the game engines were
better I like the Soul Reapers those
engines were better in the gameplay
probably was better but I just like that
James Cain story and how you know he
became a vampire any abilities he had
and I loved the voice acting of him like
he would go through and kill the bosses
and he talked in his massive I don't
know it was something about
Van vampyre yeah that was actually yeah
Amy Hennig and um yeah I really loved
that it was so well written I had no
idea until recently that was Amy inning
and um I loved that game man
absolutely yeah yeah blood oh man and
defiance and all those games have some
but yeah it's just one of those games
that I feel that you know it could make
a big comeback they could really bring
it back and people will embrace it I
don't know we just don't have too many
games like that out there right now yeah
no it's true it's absolute good choices
man very good so let's get into um now
how do you got into the YouTube game you
know creating your channel and then also
you know would let you to all these
great pockets you're a lot oh you're a
member of like a lot of really good
pocket it
we've had on the show so let's stop yeah
it's really weird because when I first
dropped some content on YouTube it was
just kind of uh I don't know like my
very first video was a video I made
about the gaming industry and where it
was headed with all these well loot
boxes and stuff and DLC and all this
stuff and it was just a i opening video
that i put out there that some people
embrace some people didn't some people
hated it and this was back in 2016 and
my channel wasn't really growing and i
was making a few other videos and then I
started making these gaming parody
videos of the community that I found
here on YouTube
I just thought some of these characters
where were rather funny and I decided to
put out some parodies and stuff and
those started to take off and people
were you know sharing them and stuff and
then I got the attention of some bigger
youtubers that would come by and I see
him in my comments I'm like whoa this
guy's got like 30 thousand subs what the
hell is he doing in my comment section
you know I'm just an old dude here you
know I'm you know I wasn't expecting to
get the attention many of these guys
that's all Lords either we were to say
we're to say what Brandon and then you
know just started make focusing more on
gaming because I was doing stuff like
political and stuff and don't ever do
political special oh I was having people
coming down on me like you know get rid
of those videos because they were just
toxic yeah it's just like I wasn't
trying to be toxic but anytime you go
political or religion or anything yeah
death sentence for your channel for
absolutely completely and as the Lord we
definitely try to we strive to stay away
from their stuff we like I want to come
here for gaming having fun escape all
that a lot of stuff because I the other
day that's what it's about you know
everybody here you know to feel
comfortable if you play playstation for
a monster boo I don't even care if you
down on your phone cuz I my phone game
is every when I'm tired
oh I said oh this badly
I want everybody to feel comfortable yes
so I stuck to gaming I just stuck the
game in in in and all of a sudden the
you know again I had some gaming
youtubers come to me and say hey you
want to be part of this you want to join
this podcast actually it was all day
Digital was the first guys yeah salute
all day today all day digital he hit me
up in a DM on Twitter I got a I got a
mention that John killed him too
oh my god he goes hey dude do you want
to come too and I'm like dude on Twitter
yeah I'm just like okay and I know what
a pocket yes going at the time I had a
mixed martial arts podcast right and I
was like okay
this is a gaming podcast I'll try it out
so I went over there and met came again
stuff and there were good people and
they asked me hey you know after the
first show they're like you want to be a
permanent guest our panel member Mike so
started then I got hit up by Porter Rock
nice little pata rock rolls like a man
you want to come to the show and then I
said yeah and then he asked me to be a
panel member over there on 60 frames so
I was like okay cool and then one day me
and all day we're talking and we're like
hey we wanna we were coming up with the
idea for Luke chess for quite some time
it was months in the making and we were
like you know we want to make a radio
style old-school podcast you know it's
out there for the people with gaming
strictly just all consoles no BS no
fanboy stuff and as we were talking then
all the sudden got hit up by dealer he's
like you know I want to make new
podcasts on my own called RDX RDX
solutely is true and he asked me to be
part of that and then
oldsalty gaming I met him he was doing
his thing and I met him when he was just
like a hundred something subscribers he
was like you know nothing yet but I
watched his content and I hit him up and
I said Amen you make good videos I like
what you do you're gonna get bigger
I'm telling you tell you can tell yeah
same thing I could tell the song because
we agreed to talk we lost another
country we had the same kind of
conversations I'm like look so it's
gonna be he's gonna be somebody he
always kept his word we always stayed in
contact go people shouting Lord X bot in
the chat and og in the chat Bob rapping
each artists is beautiful guys so salty
you know he decided to make his little
podcasting he had something going on
like dad's of gaming or something at the
time but you know we didn't really talk
much I just hit him up a few times he
came over to my channel hit me up a few
times and then one day I was on the
saltiest podcast with him and then he
asked me to be a panel member the rest
is history there and then of course Luke
chess finally came to fruition and me
and all day started that yeah with
Enrique from braaap and of course
saltiest gaming was on there for a bit
he had to leave but he came back last
night for a guest spot so it's just that
you know sometimes he can't make it so
you know it's just it is what it is but
yeah so it's a lot of podcasts and a lot
of times I'm not able to make them all
and everything but amen you know I do
what I can
well it goes to show like you know how
much people appreciate your perspective
you know like I said before in the intro
you're so balanced so cool you know and
um we definitely definitely hey you'd
make sometimes you even make people who
had one view of something sometimes what
I like what you do especially your
production bags are excellent I mean if
anybody's not watching Jeff Rossen Riley
please subscribe to the channel like he
really you know if you if you're an OG
Lord you'll appreciate some of the
subtle things he puts in his videos if
you're full-time you understand what
that here's the thing though like I used
to try and put so much production value
in my latest video that I put out about
Nintendo I put in about four hours work
for it
four-minute video I could tell and the
thing is is like I've put in before like
15 hours on one video and it barely gets
any movement so that's the problem with
YouTube it's like some guy could go out
there and just talk over a black screen
and get a thousand views I can put out a
video I put fifteen hours into and get a
hundred views and it's kind of
disconcerting it's like it makes me you
know I'm happy that some people enjoy it
but at the same time you know it's a
little bit of a knife in the back but
yeah it's tough because yeah like lucky
said it's like sometimes you know you
could tell you know in Lords like you
and people who really take that time and
make high-quality content and it's just
like man you know this Lord should be
getting so much more views you know and
then you know meanwhile you turn down
the dial and you you see what other
people are building you like damn that's
women at the same time we know where
you're coming from we know you're coming
from a passionate place and at the end
of the day you know real recognize real
it's gonna blow in and especially with
with the Lord's here we we want to
recognize all that you know and you're
definitely a pillar in this community to
them like sometimes I'll just listen to
the audio cues on some of the stuff that
you hit and it's so spot-on that I'm
like yeah that's them Lane he in that
pocket now maybe you didn't get the
views on it um but for a lot of people
that resonated like man when there's
already havee glow King he had the og o
destro those bikes that's the thing I
like to do when I make a video I like to
put myself into these videos I like to
go back and think about like with this
lady's video when I was a child the
things that I had the things that I
wanted the things that I was into you
know and put that out there for people
because I know it'll resonate with
somebody out there that is like me and
that's the one thing I had a lot of
people come to me after that last video
and tell me you know that actually
brought a lot of memories back
and you really touched me with this
video or whatever and you know even if
it's just a handful of people that makes
me feel good
honest absolutely and that's what it's
all about that's what it's all about and
like I said we just want to always
recognize that you know and the last
question to have for you those probably
silly it's probably self-explanatory but
uh the funds are really what's the deal
actually actually I work at a steel mill
okay okay and I work with a bunch of
dudes that some of them younger some of
them older but this sounds like
Pittsburgh talk now yeah it's actually
the steel mills in Pittsburgh California
oh it's Berg but it's in California but
anyway so um because my last name is
similar to Fonzarelli it's a play on my
last name to come up to me in this one
older dude at my job
he just one day came up to me he goes eh
Fonzo and I was like okay cool whatever
and then the next day he was like a
Fonzarelli and it just stopped like
everybody call me Fonzarelli go it's a
real-life nickname that I just decided
to take over to you - nice
Twitter and everything else guys love it
love it again for us all Lords we
appreciate it so let's get into what the
Lord's been playing this week we start
with our guest Lauren's really what
games have you got a chance to touch
outside of all those great videos you
can make what okay right now the latest
game I was playing is an old game it's
Witcher 3 so through that but yeah on
the Xbox one X it's beautiful oh now
which mode you do what you're doing at
60 frames you doing it what you're doing
I only do 60 frames all day when that
mode is available that's what I'm
picking okay so just a little witch
anything else I'll just been which has
been dominating town well I recently
beat last week I beat years for finally
and I thought that was a solid game cool
Lord addict Thea calls with the cold
Mouse I know you've been working a lot
again she's got a chance to play
anything I've seen you did a blood-borne
string recently yeah
as I hate to say this you know I don't
know why but I don't wanna play
blood-borne anymore this sound like this
game broke you what's going on well it's
not that it broke me is it's not that
it's a bad game stream it kind of
forcibly but you know like I'm just not
enjoying it anymore so maybe it's just
because like I kind of want to try
persona for once and it's like part of
me is like trying to yank me away from
blood-borne to play persona but the
other part of me is like if you do that
you're never going back to blood-borne
so it's like you get you'll be
grudgingly powering through it's great
it's not that blood-borne is bad or
anything it's just like I want to play
persona like like I only really play my
playstation when I'm streaming it's just
like every time I'm playing it I'm like
I could be playing persona right now
like why am I playing blood boy like I
don't know I took a long break from
blood-borne and the game is still
relatively easy I'm not really too too
far I'm in the the Cathedral where
there's a dude on on a roof shooting a
Gatling gun at me but like even when you
know you find out how to get through
that it's just like okay so I just keep
moving
like the gala guns not gonna touch me I
don't think I've gotten killed one time
with that guy look gun yeah I'm sure you
know someone is is enough to look at it
but yeah gives you the time stamp I
bring that to you hold a chat big dope
thanks for all salute low Fastback punk
dish everybody man thank you please hit
those likes much appreciated now for you
why you keep changing your name from the
og man you got to respect a little egg
loafer he's on Planet Xbox
yeah I heard him off I heard him on
multi-verse really respect we got eggs
body yanking people from Planet Xbox for
guests like first it was jazz going
around the routes now
salute Lord Edgar salute I did it my
feet take him away some license from you
and need some loyalty fees would you
been rocking this week Oh
this week you know the fraction rallies
dropped down on destiny so my destiny
every character has the suits unlocked
with all that new monarchy ornaments
with done I got the I got the Dead all
did no I got the future war cult I'm
upset with the gun situation but again
destiny takes two steps forward one step
back
it is alright umm I'm dealing with it
but that's my diction and like Lois
officer I am a crackhead one step
forward in six days but is my drug of
choice and I would go out of my way to
say they were climbing a hill and to
like just tripped and fell down the
whole thing but I'm gonna get my
druthers let's get over good I will tell
you that there's help for that you can
get off of that crack someone please
direct came to the nearest uh you know
Hope Center like that I was playing a
pub gee sir I'm pretty sure that you're
well-versed in that so shout out to Lord
monkey in our pub gee love then that
game is you going with a mindset and in
the - that we use when you jumping out
that plane you say to yourself I want a
chicken dinner today
summer plate match I'm gonna get my
joint I'm a huddle up especially if
you're going by yourself you know I'm
gonna do this this way and then some
days you just jump out of the plane and
black effort everybody gonna get it I
see somebody sneaking a popping off I
don't care if I have a parachute next
today bears you yes you flying down when
I'm looking at him like boys we hit the
ground of a punch in the face
I mean I'm kind of in the same boat as
Lord King I actually I was looking
forward to factory rally unfortunately
in destiny too they started to mess that
up there's a big big controversy right
now well right now it's bad and tally
everytime Cognito says when the distant
queue me it's going it's really bad
right now that kind of praise money
every fellas in it without what I'm
playing again I do it's like it's like
they just can't get out of the way what
is it like it's like they can't get
right it's like it's always something so
this week it was faction rally I'm so
looking forward to it cuz like Lord King
said you know I'm new moeraki they have
some of the best season 2 armor going
it's like this gold royal with the lion
it looks beautiful and they have like
all these different requirements to
unlock each piece so I'm about to do it
and I'm a lot of people are saying like
hey do you realize that a lot of the new
weapons aren't dropping and I'm like oh
I kid about was OMA but it's it started
to pick up and then they had to explain
themselves as to why this wasn't
happening
it was another PR mess and I'm like come
on destiny so you know shadow soluta
it's a CJ Barret you know he's jumping
in the front lines with our deej and
these guys but um it's getting bad Fonz
and I know you were a hardcore destiny
guy it's getting bad good point yeah I
know I know because I remember you an
RDX I was like yeah like that guy you
used to have the little hunter logo oh
yeah I got you know I I put over 200
hours into the second game and I just
got to that end game and there was no
end game snowing like it was so bad and
this was a for Osiris of course
absolutely and I was like you know I'm
done with this and I stopped playing
especially after all the controversy
that was going around at that time with
but ah and then my son you know my son
still plays it he's 12
and yes for Osiris for Christmas so I
got him that and he's like just download
it you got it we game share anyway just
then I'm like nah not their part an hour
and a half after he loaded that up he
said I'm done with a with a campaign and
I'm like what yeah it's like an hour and
a half I was like yes it's that fast
crazy and you know of course there's
other stuff you can do but it's just not
worth much it's like what I tell my
hardcore destiny guys like you right now
they're in a mix of revamping the entire
thing it's gonna take time it might not
even be by the next DLC but they're
gonna have to wait to have their taken
king moment to get Lord addict to get
you more Fonz back in because there's so
many things it's right now there the
process of bringing things back to
destiny one you know and the whole
ostracion is why was it removed in the
first place alright so that's another
discussion no no we had this talk shout
the lordy bonta's he was on you know
last week we lost sinister and we went
into the development up they please
catch that episode we talked about our
theories about what's going on and that
stuff so it's intense but for the
hardcore hold the line think about maybe
that September one that's the one went
by then based on the road map everything
that we want should come back but as far
as on me besides the facts rally I
actually picked up on old-school Double
Dragon on a switch knows the feels it
caught me there's so much what do you
know arcade or that game well far I will
say with destiny though nothing else
touches that gunplay though yeah
unmasking phenomenal and in Lord addict
knows when you have that game playing
six people cooperative and rain it is
some of the funnest memories I've had
with both Lord addict looking more
sinister
we have moments and that's why be if
people want to know like why can't you
guys just quit destiny it's for those
moments really put the nail on the head
the feeling and the visceral feel of
that gun
rumble in there controller and the
weight I don't know how they can confuse
my brain into feeling the weight of the
gun but it's in sane like you know also
the hit detection - I mean it is nuts
will you play Wolfenstein doesn't do the
guns feel light don't they feel floaty
don't they don't they don't feel they
don't have that gravitas
if you pick up that sidearm and in
destiny and you let off that side oh man
that you looking at the clip run down
and it's an audio cue to it - like you
know that you're running out you're
switching to the next gun and you like
bam bam bam it's the film they're
getting playing I'm so rooting for them
that I just can't get off the ship now
I'm already this far in the ocean i'ma
drown if I get on salute the psycho gave
me the check you say all day digital
that's what's up man good work in the
building and yeah American foot you are
right your division right now that 1.8
is kind of popping I ain't gonna lie
it's gonna get it love in the
conversation loving the conversation you
brought me back to some of my days and
you were talking about this the way you
do your podcasts and I think that's
what's great about the community is to
bring people back to their childhood
memories of gaming that's a great thing
everything that's what it's about man oh
I think I hit that senior demographic
you hit the Toys R Us kid that's we we
grew up with that I don't wanna grow up
I'm a toys that feel that's all my mom
listen my man came downstairs is desings
desta essence of that you walk in it you
like man this - this wallet
this is the time capsule of I'm taking
him back to play playing with big wheels
and stuff last week's LP poll results
they're in and the people have spoken to
the question with a tremendous success
of the switch is Nintendo getting a pass
for continuing to port or remaster Wii U
games examples like mario mario kart
mario tennis Hyrule warriors etc to the
switch the winner at 47% in a fairly
competitive three-way IOP poll is the
null it's smart business most skipped
out on the way you group coming in at
second place at 35 percent was the yes
these are cash grabs and old appease
third place a shallow crew was the I
don't care what's up with that Smash
Brothers no building things all
participating ever notice one of every
one of your choice always is like
sarcasm like its but you know what's
funny the last two polls what I do like
the shallow or the quote-unquote sarcasm
they've actually won or been second
place because that's how everyone
legitly feels like but it evokes you an
anchorman you guys have that feel like
so the eggs everywhere real quick really
lets out you what do you think about
what the people are saying about the Wii
U ports and what's your whole stance on
that I you know what a lot of times I do
say that Nintendo gets passes for a lot
of things but in this situation when
when not a lot of gamers have
experienced these games I you know
they're fresh they're new to all these
people so you know if they port these
over nobody touched and one that we you
so they can experience them here now and
I think it's a smart business move I
really do yeah absolutely lost frog we
got you to build and Scylla
you think about these uh these ports
coming oh and you think it's it's good
business do you think it's just cash
grab where were you at with this well as
a Nintendo you know every console on our
own do we you and I would honestly say
yeah there's a lot of games I didn't
particularly want to see come back but I
think it's smart business because we and
his own right wasn't very successful so
I think this is smart business-wise for
the the fan base it didn't get to play
the games in these these are phenomenal
games I mean Donkey Kong is a great game
huh you know but for me personally uh
there's a lot of games I don't like I
don't want to be by this I don't
everybody's because I had a Wii U but as
far as looking at Nintendo on it and
then giving a product to the consumer
base out there I think it's very smart
business so you know I think it's more
business I think it's smart my business
absolutely absolutely
more King I know you uh think me you
were on the same page for this right
she's old you but she new to me dollars
went into these games and you're gonna
stretch it our Capcom has been using
that same format forever if you've
looked at it you know these guys have a
great game have a new system and in
between launching these blockbuster
games that they they have in development
for years let's put out the games that
we put in development for years on the
other system that didn't get that
recognition or didn't get seen as much
and let's put those out let's see if it
hits
if it resumes it does if it doesn't it
doesn't you know some people did get the
Wii U I got the Wii U and my mind Donkey
Kong fries yes just because they're cool
Kong dude that cool Kong dude was not
inside the Donkey Kong fries that I have
so I have to get that one in a low attic
I'm assuming you you you okay you don't
know actually I'm on the tender side
this time Wow okay like these are the
same people you know like look like
regardless how you feel about these
games coming out ain't nobody said
nothing about it
Mike Rosario out the Master Chief
collection that's five Noah's said
nothing about them breeding of how many
different versions did they bring back
with fable fable anniversary they
actually would he brought them all out
once on all the fables in one package
killer instinct was a remake mmm that
was a little bit different of a story I
mean they literally brought the rare
collection which was like 30 right
you're a Last of Us remake absolutely if
you look at the start of the generation
the majority of it was remastered from
the 360 and ps3 if you if you like this
is my counter to that Cod that you know
that argument every time comes up what's
a game that is they're talking about
right now so let's say what's a good
game I can use this for the shadow
losses no I'm talking about for Nintendo
oh for Nintendo that's mean we matter
yeah tomorrow came out tomorrow if that
game didn't come out tomorrow nothing
you have the option not to buy so yeah
man we're gonna get into these topics
now uh well frog I'm not the board you
and Lord addict cuz uh we got a special
little topic for this kid towards more
Fonzarelli
cuz I yeah it is mm a podcast before and
he's a he's a lord of combat sports
yesterday was a big day encompass was we
had um Showtime boxing we had a UFC 220
Bellator blew up that he that he won
like my Twitter blew it was crazy it's
something that my Twitter blows out with
MMA news what's a building gonna have a
quick segment here law files did you
catch any what did you catch last night
what are your impressions
I caught the UFC main card and I caught
a little bit of
Bellator not much of it but I saw that
it was all decisions basically yeah you
know you know but man I was pretty
impressed with the way the steep a
fought holy versus Francis ain't God who
the predator dude I'm expecting a
knockout on that fight and Wow and
kognito you you were the one that told
me you know we got to see if steep a or
if Gandhi was gonna last after the first
second round and yeah right on the head
man absolutely
fought a beautiful beautiful fight and a
lot of people were telling me I was a
boring fight I'm like what the dude it
was a masterful fight it's a fight for
those people and pound your forehead and
twist your leg out about mixed martial
arts yeah a lot of people are saying
Isis GSP left not so a lot of people are
I've seen some boring fights but but
when it comes to mixed martial arts a
lot of people will tell me I like the
old do UFC back in the day when anything
goes and all this stuff I said you want
to see some real boring fights watch
that old stuff cuz they'd land on the
ground for 25 years
nobody telling the standup yeah I mean
well no here's the thing I I appreciate
a good ground game I appreciate
jiu-jitsu I appreciate all facets of
mixed martial arts that's what it's
about but back then they knew nothing of
digits that's why you had people like
moist Gracie cousin dominating the
funniest and this is how he was set it
up to be like boxer versus karate
yeah I got that boxer until the boxer
leg is taken out and you see your
favorite boxer on the floor being choked
out by a kung fu G
he's almost like set up the old ones
almost set up like a bloodsport kumite
got it all the generations of it I mean
yes the blood sport aspect was fun yeah
don't get me wrong I had fun watching it
back then too but there were some boring
fights where they just laid there yeah
25 minutes it was ridiculous absolutely
nowadays like you know if you're really
into the game and you understand what's
going on when they go to the ground and
what they're trying to pull off with
these submissions and stuff you should
respect what steep eight did last night
absolutely man
I was not expecting him to win and and
look I I was you know what I'm mad at
myself and I'm eating crow because I
shouldn't have went against the champ
you know because that's my rule of thumb
you never go against the champ
you know he showed in Ghana why he's
there and and it really impressed me
he didn't listen to the talk on the
paper because on paper he was supposed
to be locked out of 31 seconds as a
champion if you looked at some of those
betting lines the betting lines told you
they had a betting line that had 31
seconds in the first punch landed that
this guy was gonna beat him like I never
know clad people have been screwed my
whole life than I am right now
what I noticed if you notice the key to
his whole thing was trapped in that leg
when he was on the floor like trapping
his leg and I don't know I just saw a
sense of panic in this guy's face that's
eyes and it was what is what you just
nailed it is what me and funds really
we're talking about because my concern
is like like we all know if in Ghana
catch him it's night-night right but the
thing is my back woman okay what happens
if he does it what's gonna happen one we
gotta see we're in Ghana's cardio is now
I never knew steep a to be a great
wrestler but for him employ that
gameplan just show me how intelligent he
was and how like Lauren's really was
saying like keeping him pressed up
against the cage putting that body
weight you know I'm just wearing the big
man down so that each subsequent room
the punches don't have that sting right
because in Ghana did catch him a couple
times I mean he got he got rocked but he
was he was still in the mix like putting
pretty much every round he was kind of
in danger
but to give him credit man I I actually
tweeted I was like Stevie Bob Living God
no credit for not giving up
yes because he could have quit like a
lot of bullies do yeah I know when when
the pressure is on them and when they're
down and then in the corner there's the
fighters out of them you see the dog
leave like like somebody yelled out
yesterday on my Twitter feed I miss I
miss Brock Lesnar Brock Lesnar is the
epitome of a real bully when it don't
work he folds up like a ham sandwich
start out to big boy who took his
whooping because he got hey listen they
got hxhx is good so he got paid to fight
and he fought the best he could but one
dude understood the key that Lake know
down low frog did you catch any if you
know you can't knock code snippets after
oh I usually try to catch it when it's
going on I had to watch it live as it's
happening I didn't
I was a little busy but yeah i'm i love
mixed martial arts I'm a huge crazy fan
worried I was boring you to say Gracie
fan I did a lot of mixed martial arts
and stuff when I was in the military
always have enough you know yeah yeah I
love that stuff I think it's um it's
become the boxing - come back - no but I
love I love it I love to see it I love
to see like he's you know like like you
were saying the intelligence of the
fighters that's really to me when you
see a fighting you can tell them if I
it's good you can see the person that
they're not just using their brute
strength they are intelligent they're
thinking about every move they're
thinking about how to counter this
person and it just it really shows it
these people are just more than just a
muscle they're intelligent you know
that's what I like to see I like to see
fights like that I like to see you know
somebody really used that okay well I
can't do this I can't do that well I
gotta use what I got in in an
intelligent way to take this opponent
out and that's that's the best fights
those are the best fights absolutely and
of course we had another car fight on
that car no phones really we had a DC
and what would your impressions of that
one alright my first thought about this
is what the hell was Vulcan doing in
there against him anyway
I know the guys on a five win streak but
three of those are the only ones in the
UFC and he beat dudes like me Shakur
keukenhof Kirk Yadav and Jimmy Manawa
and Jimmy manna was alright but it's
alright
come on I mean over say he did beat
ovince st. Preux but it was by split
decision and I think that the dude had
no business in there all right I just
think that they couldn't get that fight
with what's-his-name who's the dude that
john jones fought and he all majors
johnson yeah they couldn't get that
fight together because Gustafson wanted
to give it some time or something you
know and i think they threw vulcan in
there and it showed it showed there was
a guy that was just a step above
absolutely
Cormier made him made him look bad
absolutely I think so I mean and that's
it to touch back world and Donnell it
kind of reminded me the fights kind of
mirrored each other to me because it was
one of those things that once plan a
doesn't work and then it had to go to
the ground they just both looked lost
like they didn't know what to do
especially Vulcan like he he didn't know
what was going to be not he's lucky
after round one member he was done like
he got Saved by the Bell
he's getting choked out why the second
counted I totally agree with you man I
am really real quick loss funds what do
you think DC goes from here there's
rumors now of him possibly going up to
to heavyweight you know because steep a
may have flushed out the division we
don't know if Kane's coming back he
mentioned he mentioned afterwards that
Kane's coming back oh god I don't want
to hear that mess because honestly
Kane's always hurt I don't want to
because he's always he's always getting
pulled out but you know he the problem
was he those guys at aka they trained so
hard and especially came with the way he
fights in his cardio he's always
susceptible to injuries well it's not
fair to the division you're right and
and you hit it on the head they do train
too hard some camps they spar really
hard like they're really fighting and
stuff and that kind of stuff I've heard
other fighters talk against that you
lose yourself in the gym he's always
getting hurt he's always getting hurt in
the gym so yeah
the difference between you know boxing
and MMA when you go into a boxing
training camp you have how many rounds
you're gonna spa there you're gonna have
how many rounds you're gonna you know
bag work and stuff like that all this
stuff is like petered out if a real
trainers working with you
this stuff is all programmed into what
you're gonna do per day and rest is key
to all of it no no
so speaking of rest Lord King I'm gonna
pass that to you as far as the UH boxing
day I gotta be honest like I was shot at
the lottery 2002 you guys put me on to
something last night that I was very
pleased about sore telling people what
was going down with Showtime boxing
right quick you can stand up next to
your laptop or your computer your phone
right now you can put your hand in here
and understand that New York City was
rocking last night you know you have
Brooklyn it was in the house Manhattan
was lit with the UFC New York City I
mean you felt it in the air people
wanted to fight you wanted to get it in
you know I was driving past somebody
like watch it watch it so I felt the
energy and you know the champ was in the
streets air especially if you don't know
he's the second coming of of everything
that's great about boxing um we're gonna
start with the undercard we had Robin
Ystad jr. versus Fontana Xavier Fontana
that kid Fontana he was so he he lost it
he lost the fight on it on the scales
when you don't respect the lady make
weight
no he didn't make weight he came in
overweight and sometimes that's a tactic
for people need you understand if they
feel that they can't beat the champ or
they can't beat somebody they come in
overweight and he tried to use that
weight you know that low action those
what extra pounds they did it doesn't
matter no look at GSP
yeah it does it does serious so he came
in overweight so even if he would have
won he winner got the belt but what you
saw was the pedigree of a champion
Robert Eastern jr. boxes is all for
rounds and leaned on her but shorty was
in us in the pocket hitting them and
yelling and trying to get you know
trying to steal rounds like you would do
like rally at the end and throw your
hands out real quick and stuff like that
but he deserved the loss he got
penalized for punching in the back of
the head but what everybody came for and
this is the new boogeyman of boxing yeah
you know
Errol spends June if you don't know him
the boogeyman of boxing the reason why
he's the boogie man
remember everybody understand why Floyd
was so successful no drinking no eating
[ __ ] fool mills and stuff like that
and no fluctuating between weights
between fights and being sensible right
yeah I could say anything I want about
Floyd there's never been any drugs he
doesn't you know womanizer zesting
everybody got a drug but the key to his
success was he didn't abuse his body
that's why they're 40-something you old
man right now I can go out there and
whip a lot of dudes but else when Junior
is the epitome of the Floyd Pretty Boy
Floyd camp yeah he definitely has that
that vibe definitely has that one his
stains the way through you know I won't
say his defenses are the level but alone
I'm eclectic looking like you know low
father like I haven't watched boxing a
long time you know I've converted to UFC
MMA about the last five to six years and
I have I was just so disgusted with
boxing like I grew up with the whole you
know my Jones era
Oscar De La Hoya is the you know flowing
the pretty boy not when he was mourning
me you know say that those are the guys
I like you know if and Holyfield's and
the tails in there runner like those of
the era I like so when that kind of went
out and it was a lot of corruption and I
stuff it kind of turned me off and in
MMA kind of came up on the rise and then
I kind of stuck with it so shout alone
record yourself Lord King you know
telling me about this offense kid having
lunch box in a while and I tuned in I
said all right let me see I have to
admit if you guys are not boxing guys
this is a
kid to watch you know me he's undefeated
he really fundamentally sound when it
comes to early anything anyone
undefeated it's always fun to watch
nobody he's beaten some cool people from
nice people on the resume and he just
looks danger I was hitting the god he
was fighting was a top contender like
what his game can penned with like
things that a normal person would fold
and I don't even know how that guy was
it what was this guy I'm sitting at
Wheaton Rick when you're like I don't
understand how this guy is still
standing up under this heat and it went
more impressive about Errol Spencer jr.
was not his cardio his work rate and
it's just just he just looks like a
beast man so your saloon law came from
make me watch it out what uh you might
have me watch boxing for this kid but
this kid he is Terry Norris if you
remember terrible Terry Norris back in
the days where he hits you and you like
oh my god he hit that guy I think he
broke his head oh this kid his jab he
started off cuz I I guess Petersen
thought he was gonna come in he was on
bullying because Peterson shoulders he
looked like he got shoulder pads on when
he fights he stood in front of them and
he said that's not the place to be
tonight bro like I'm going to keep
hitting you until you move and he was
hitting him and he and then Peterson
Thailand a good shot and when when you
hit somebody with your best shot I take
it and they actually smile and it's not
like I'm smiling for the cameras you
know no he took this shot he smiled at
him like that's what I wanted you to do
like I said he's trying to kill him and
at the end of the fight when they said
to stop the fight he was his corner was
like nah man you guys stop it was a
round too too late to be honest with me
I've been - yeah like I said but he told
him you supposed to die on a battlefield
this is his mentality so unless somebody
drags you out of there I'm there to kill
you on this battlefield and have you
shot that he hit this man with I'm
pretty sure Peterson feels it to day
those body shots he's not me not going
to the bathroom right
there's
out there coming from different offices
out of his body in that total balls a
day and shout out for him from my sport
for taking those beatings and for my
entertainment little fuzz like I said
check out this kid I know you mmm aid to
the call and I'm pretty much the same
way but this is somebody that if he
fights I'm gonna pay attention to it oh
you know there's some times I'll watch
somebody fight in boxing and it really
impresses me there's certain fights out
there that are great it's just that
usually the main spectacle fights you
know are usually not the ones to watch
you know
yeah McGregor and whether you use the
right word for that that was a spectacle
and I don't know why anybody thought
somebody with no boxing history was
gonna go in there beat a master boxing
like Cognito I go way back I go to the
Hearns the doing anglers you know dude
Sugar Ray back in the day I used to
watch all those fights with my dad as a
young and you know and and just like
love watching that stuff and then as I
got older it grew into the the Evander
Holyfield's the Tyson's home Tyson is my
all-time favorite boxer oh by in his
prime he could not be beat yeah I don't
care who he was in front of he was gonna
maul the that I used to box to spar with
a lot of these top heavyweights stuff
like that and the word in the streets
the word in the streets is you know when
they did spar when he was younger
Holyfield started getting the best of
them Mike lost his cool but um Holyfield
always pursued that fight and Don King
you know send Tyson to jail by giving
him a tax attorney as a trial lawyer
because he was on drugs doing this thing
um backdoor stuff for your guys uh so
when he came out Tyson was bigger than
ever you understand but
was never gonna be a guy that can box
him that wasn't afraid of him that
wasn't you know because Tyson was
someone like you go back when you go
back and watch old footage of both of
these guys in their prime Evander and
Tyson it - was a madman I'd never seen
anybody punch his hardest man it was
crazy but absolutely you know and and
after all that they did the stuff that
was going on then people were talking
about fix fights and all this stuff I
really wanted you to go because I love
the dirtiness of that sport you notice
that these guys are always fighting in
these Indian casinos and these and they
do that purposely because peds run
rampant
[Applause]
you got you got the Lord of all pd's
Chael Sonnen fighting oh yeah if shale
is fighting the league that's a problem
and then you got these fixed bites I
mean you look at some of these fights
you're like really who was a Gracie
versus shamrock
that was totally rigged there was this
one fight this one time with some
nobodies and I'm not lying to you guys I
wish I could find this fight on YouTube
or something I could not find it after
this I wish I would have recorded it but
this dude was getting uppercut it up
against the cage and and it was throwing
fast uppercuts and the guy's head was
bobbing up and down boom boom boom you
know and then the dudes stop throwing
uppercuts and the dudes head kept
bobbing up and down like he was getting
punched it was like it was worse than
like
wrestling acting you know it was so bad
oh one last leg the rampage win or was
it won by decision men like though
everyone reacts too much it was kind of
like to see you citizens to know like I
said I still watch him but it's kind of
wack that was the first card of the year
first good card of yeah and I'm glad
that UFC and boxing is walking this road
hand-in-hand because they've been doing
it all last year could I say about peds
though because I saw X body you know I
know he's joking he's all this CDs go
you know more entertainment but here's
the problem with peds and this this
stems into football as well and every
other sport
I think peds lend a hand to all these
domestic violence cases and stuff and
that's why I'm against like you know all
the stuff being used because if you look
at the correlation between
PDUs within a sport and domestic
violence it's huge
there's a Durst there's something going
on there and I think that might lend a
hand into that and that's why I'm gonna
have to go to the other side on that
because you we all know that you know
WWE M wrestling and stuff like that
that's all they do is use that so in the
domestic violence cases in WWE and
wrestling situations is lower than it is
in football now you're probably gonna
say that there's more football players
than is WWE or Wrestling Federation's so
you wanna um skew the numbers to fit but
what I might say is this if you train
someone to be an animal for X amount of
time on the field some people can't turn
that switch off
exactly oh I don't think you know it is
it's pretty much either the drugs that
they use and I just feel like once you
turn somebody into that animal
and anytime confrontation hits them or
any type of roadblock to them in life
they can be in the store
and the guy tells them whoa no you
didn't buy that you have to pay for that
and then take it to a totally different
way right holes to another individual so
if you train somebody to be a killing he
does kill the things it's not the
killers fault this is a trainer so um I
will say this I'm not a proponent for
peds but I'm not gonna blame everything
that happens and verse Leon PD no I
wouldn't blame everything either I'm
just saying some of these there's a
correlation there
I love you gotta flee this year's attic
I was scrolling through my facebook oh
it was a big week for Microsoft I mean
they made the announcement that they
promoted
Mammootty to leader from he's previously
from minecraft game business so now he's
gonna be the corporate VP of Microsoft
Studios was another edition by Satya
Nadella and Phil Spencer so he's gonna
basically overtake that phil spencer
role i thought it was interesting that
he's gonna be all
seeing developing publishing a lot of
Mexico AAPC and multiple laughs laws and
that actually um he's actually gonna be
running the head that which includes
three four three
coalition Mojang which he was previously
brought up rare turn 10 and global
publishing so all those like Barney Ross
and Shan Shannon Loftus and I believe
Allen Fergus Alan Hartman and Ferguson
up and turn turn ten in the coalition
these guys will all report to Booty now
so he and Phil Spencer as well and they
talked about what an imposter in every
process that Phil had spoke them about
was that you know what aspect of aiming
or you historically associate it whether
it be the business side creative side or
his story you know the harm technical
side he products said it was a mixture
of all because um basically used to be a
developer he worked as a CEO also at
Midway so he got the exposure to the
business side but um he definitely got a
little bit of a mix of all three and one
of his philosophies was actually just to
let the gaming teams just do their thing
and actually provide just assistance to
the studio so I thought that was pretty
interesting and I wanted to bring this
to the Lords you know obviously it's the
weak reign of the bully we're gonna
bring it to law Fonzarelli first and
then we get lured wrapping a frog in it
as well you know what do we think about
this is this positive what was your
overall impressions of sentinels Lord
fines are really a random good let's go
I think one positive thing I could take
away from this cuz I don't know much
about booty to be honest
15 seconds giggling every time booty
comes up this is the best name we had
just resi Fiza me look I got eight kids
I know a lot about booty but I think
Matthew booty this promoting him is a
much better I think God to promote then
some of the other people and I won't
mention any names that I thought well
you said it and I was dreading that I
was reading that just because of the
games and everything that we have first
party now like zoo tycoon and you know
super Lucky's tale and things like this
I mean that's great for the kids and all
but I want those adult games I want some
games to come to the the brand that
really speak to us as adult gamers and I
just think that she wouldn't have
brought that in that position I think
that booty I think he'll do it for us I
think I think he'll bring bring some
allows you to think that he's gonna
bring a dope oh there's there's there's
nothing in his resume cuz I don't know
much about his resume
I'm just hoping for that I'm hoping for
huh so you taught me better than what
she had on our resume and how cuz our
indication was to go younger where
education is open basically I'm looking
at the track record that that we know of
with her and I don't like it process
behind it as well because I felt that um
I think Phil is a genius all right so I
don't care what anybody saying but you
know come at me for that but I think
Phil is a genius when he takes the
individual that nobody can pretty much
argue with because not so many people
understand or know to do well and those
people that do know him well know his
accolades as far as what he has done
with Minecraft and moving in
in the direction that has gone - whereas
maybe the deal with Nintendo was the
Silla on that you know um that
relationship that he built over there so
we know that booty is in charge of this
and well you know I'm uncle yeah I'm mad
because with the man we we we know that
Matt is in charge of this section now
does that help facilitate that stuff
that we were talking about as far as the
deficiencies on Nintendo system and
brother as long as it's out there and
it's talking this chatter about it it's
possibilities for it and when one person
has a need that they have an address and
one person has an abundance of it yeah
come share this fruit bootie rain my
thoughts so initially you know I I guess
obviously the name was kind of funny
haha I'm a bootie but someone did not
just say bootie on stage you know look I
the guy has industry experience 25 years
in the industry came the industry as a
developer knows the business that's
great right I think we all assume that
they're gonna hire somebody who knew the
business the one takeaway that I'll say
and this is something that he mentioned
in the interview with I think
VentureBeat where he really wants the
studios to really interact and engage
with one another and that's something
that Sony does a lot interview that's
all reason horizon zero dawn actually
technically horizon zero dawn the ideal
came from Naughty Dog and they gave that
idea to UM it makes it guerrilla games
guerrilla games dog thought process on
the game yeah and so I think that's
that's obviously a change in direction
from what they have historically done
internally for first party perspective
so I'm on board with that I'm like great
you know you know they obviously see the
value in that they know that Sony does
it
more recently a Sony and gorilla and and
and Kojima you know have been talking
and they giving Kojima the decima engine
to for his new game so you know this
this could bring about like you know
some some sharing of ideas or some maybe
some new ideas for new titles I just
feel like and I and I said this on Bravo
Wednesday I and I'm a rant that I did
this on Thursday as well I'm sorry on
Friday I kind of feel like Dave they've
turned a corner I think for Phil you
know he had a very hard job coming into
this too in 2013 or after 2013 they
think he'll to connect they have the
hardware in place now they got rid of
the power narrative and now they can
really focus on kind of building back up
first party right there make a good
point they it's kind of hard to make
games when you know your games that you
make are gonna be attacked for under
underperforming uncle yeah well the
hallways solidified right they they've
got that like law Brad was saying it's
down so now you know like you saying
like that now they can actually get the
focus onto the games and this is the one
in charge but continue continue liberals
are you don't know which and I think the
the only thing I'm going to say just
kind of temper everyone's expectations I
don't think we're going to see an influx
you know for three or four new IPs at e3
2018 this year I think they're more
focused on the next console more so
content for that from exclusive
perspective than they are I think right
now I think right now you know the
narrative is hey you want you know you
can play the best versions of your games
on on the X and they're gonna ride with
that for a while and then it's gonna be
more of hey here's a new system and by
the way we have not only do we have the
halo of the way other gears we have you
know a sequel to yolk up head but we
also have these new IPs that are coming
out we have fate a new fable that's
coming out I think that this the focus
that we're seeing today we're not gonna
see for another couple years so maybe
China three years down the road they see
you think it's like it's an investment
on the fruits of Labor like down rolling
gosh absolutely this yeah I see your
Lord frog what do you think about the
rain
butI I think she say I think Matt being
in the position is I think he he's been
an industry for a long time a long
enough time you know he's a veteran and
as I kind of look at it you know with
him being with Midway Williams he's a
veteran you can look at you know some of
his past experiences like you know and I
remember on Twitter I think he was
talking about he had he had a quote and
his quote was similar to kind of sugar
Miyamoto's where he said you know he was
talking about games and you know Shigeru
Miyamoto says the delayed game is
eventually good game but a brush room is
bad forever and I think that philosophy
is gonna be something he implements
because of the way he he says you know
let these studios kind of do your thing
and step in when they need help but let
them have the kind of free hand I think
that's right now yeah the Xbox brand
needs that there they definitely need
that they need to be able to say okay
and you know stepping if you say you're
wasting money bad but let them kind of
have that free rein let them God and
develop are the eye peas I think this
could be a what do they say is good for
every once in while they stare at the
pot up I think this is good good idea to
stir the pot up you know see what we get
out of it I've been sitting in it this
Sony allows their developers the time to
develop let the game develop you know
and it always seems like either
Microsoft is rushing it or pushing it or
we got leaks as just you know like beam
up the ship stop if you the top two or
you're the top three act like you
definitely man just just you know let
letting the studios do their thing and
just shout to a lord be money in the
chat you know that that's one of the
things he mentioned he was just like you
know we won sometimes we feel like
sometimes Microsoft has a tendency to
kind of get in the way so it's just you
know allow with some argument allow them
to just do their thing you know and and
that's important so let's get our Lord
addict what did you feel the rain booty
we know the announcement I mean when it
comes down to I don't really think we
should be focusing you know so much I'll
man
I'm at I think what we really should be
focusing on it's a strategic area that
Phil has put himself in now that's a
good point when you get promoted to
general and you let your you let someone
in your army be you know the captain you
know you can you you are a lot more
frequent to giving the captain what he
needs
absolutely this is a great point you
know that it's certain to add on to lure
that next one I think that um you know
this is definitely a good move but Phil
you know I like that as a gaming guy in
there and I know Lord King
that's his Lord and Savior xbox so
Spencer's done so bad that Microsoft's
gonna get him like look that Microsoft
and the Microsoft and again he's not
going look at what's going on with with
Phil Spencer he be said nah I'm not
going into you know he say stuff but you
know this dude literally they made a
position for this man you know change
comes from within and change comes from
the top down trickle down so when you
put that guy that you that you believe
in his philosophy at the top and you
allow that to trickle down and then he
starts promoting and putting people in
that shares his same philosophy you
start to get this one unified movement
within a team and I feel that that was
needed like sometimes the messaging
mixed in it was all over the biggest
reasons that he got promoted so much
within is he literally took a brand that
was on the edge of death it really was
like yeah Xbox was the laughingstock of
the Internet absolutely one of the great
turnaround I mean let's be rowing it
probably would be like I wouldn't say
half but it would probably be 10 to 15
million less so to Phil Spencer when it
took what he did
who knows we see like you want to jump
in or something I was pretty much gonna
say the same thing about
he inherited a company that just was in
turmoil I mean they were the
laughingstock and and they were doing so
bad and and he's he's turned a lot of it
around and yes they focused a lot on
hardware but you know he's investing in
software now and I understand it's gonna
take some time to see some of these
games come to fruition but hey it Dell
eventually be here but look like with
the Xbox 1x I'm loving that console yes
my favorite consoles already it's become
one of my favorite love it love the I
got it from the perspective of what he
said legitly you know what I'm saying
like those pictures said his priorities
was services then his priority was
hardware and then its first party games
that I don't know maybe services and
hardware flop for some reason I feel
like it was service as far as then
hardware than games and now it's it's no
like if you look at it from the
perspective of rumors when game pass is
coming out rumors on that groomers on
the Xbox one X there's no denying it
then now we're seeing hardcore rumors on
the on the software side now it's like
it that's the exact order that he gave
yeah it's very promising for the start
of 2018 just to see a lot of this
positive you know stuff come out and
what you're hearing and you know back to
you guys overall points you know
pointing to Phil is just like you know
again this is his ship now he's getting
to shape it you know with a couple of
years removed from the matric era he's
getting to shake things in his vision
you know first party content in his
vision and I like the comment he made
that he's like he's not deaf to the meme
out there regarding investing in first
quality content stuff like that and just
a contrast to the beginning of 2017 when
you know around this time what we're
hearing about scalebound counts
cancellations all this negative stuff
and it just seems to be this kind of
like a positive vibe going right a lot
of good news trickling out and stuff
like that I just want to say something
about good news kind of just picking on
what you said Cognito I'm sure you're
not even not even like two or three days
into the new year we got leaks of you
know the fable game
mekka salt what else no matter all I
needed to hear is favor
you know rare in perfect dark so and now
you know we've we've heard so we know
now the new appointment of Matt booty
and Z huge huge put some news out there
that was no we'll get it to that's the
next time we got it and then you gotta
look for the perspective is you know
people act like this has happened
randomly I guarantee you matt has known
he's gonna get this promotion for a
couple months this is when it finally
went out publicly oh yeah oh yes have
you guys talked to Phil personally at
all yes okay so you know he's such a
nice guy like he honestly it feels like
like he's your friend when he talks to
you on you know Phil sketches the only
dude I don't know that could be a savage
on Twitter and not be a savage in person
like like this dude is a savage on
Twitter but he don't mean to be like
well he was a politically correct when I
you know spoke to me he didn't want the
PC answer for me because I gave him the
PC answer you know we had a function and
everybody is you know having a good time
and you know I got a chance to talk to
him and he asked me a question and I
gave him the PC answer and he looked at
me and was like this [ __ ] would be
yeah you going no I mean just just to
get the answer from the real answer from
him it took a it took a different term
because a lot of people I was talking to
that was there and shout at the angry
Brian Greenberg every time he sees me
gives me a hug um some of those people
there are real genuine people like
they're not dead like these corporate
type of untouchables at the top and
honorable talk to us like the elite
controller guy listen to some of the
stuff that we said and gave us reasons
for why salute Hillsdale well and and
Lord Kings right and again we're not
trying to no corporate shilling on it a
lot of it just comes down to a lot of
these executives are not approachable
we weren't fan fest and you know like
assured that these same people were
around III you know what that last event
a fan fest like I kid you not like I'm
pretty sure they told every big person
that was it that was working for the
gaming department of Microsoft look you
don't have to stay for the whole thing
they are the same there's no not and we
can smell the BS Omar when you're
looking where we from we know you know
else is like saying that you know that's
probably one of the reasons that we they
were so accessible to us is because we
to keep it real a lot of these execs
even on the Xbox side they don't game
but fill games and fill game we were
talking in and Phil has a long history
of gaming like was laid back and talked
about a lot of the same games we played
and everything so I respect that about
the man too
absolutely well I think I think honestly
Phil Spencer just wants to see gaming as
a as a as a brand that evening the Xbox
brand but just gaming it and in central
just succeed he wants to see successful
because when you talk to him you listen
to his interviews he talks about
childhood gaming he talks about the
people that bring you know when he when
he would make comments about Nintendo
and their success is because he
genuinely plays their stuff that's not
because he was that guy who's like oh
Microsoft is donor Xboxes don't he's
like I genuinely like what they're doing
and man I wish I could take some NASA
sex and put over he wants the Xbox
branded be successful so I can respect
that
hey I I appreciate the invite I'm gonna
go ahead and jump out I have some more
information we can get your grill yes I
really appreciate it everybody's
listening please like subscribe sup to
these guys
this is amazing podcast and thanks again
for the invite thanks to everybody no
pressure on frog frog nail demand me
just you know he's a gamer you know you
know it definitely it definitely comes
out in in conversations like what
Fonzarelli was saying it's just you get
that genuine sense you know and I think
that's where the fanboys lose you know
they lose it a little bit because they
want him to be like this that's like oh
you want that game not tech book mine
like you know I see you know a common in
this section of what Microsoft be like
this that they were in first place like
I don't know if we can legitimate could
have happened we did end up with that
scenario so think of you know if let's
say that they were in first place and
you know Don Mattrick still left you
still took his place details I don't
think so I think that's the thing if
they in first place I think that Don is
still running the show I'm saying in
this scenario if those picture was still
head of Xbox and they were on top those
bets are so be as humble as he is I
think Phil will be humble but I think
the issue comes down to a lot of times
the company mindset as a whole changes
and they don't necessarily feel they
have to cater as much to the game as far
as features services they looked at me
when I think that's where we see the
shift like you know with Playstation and
a mic so depending on you know who's in
the leads I think it's that over going
above and beyond you don't see as much
all right right now Microsoft was in
that feel good going above me on you
know they would be doing it because what
do you do when you have the you know
when you had the the highest install
base you know you had the most money in
the industry you focus minorly on your
first parties fun them and you just grab
all the third parties what do you think
he did this year and that's what
Microsoft did last year but you got
Lauren's really love Brad what do you
guys think if the roles were reversed
and you know that was a kid do you think
Microsoft maintain that type of
personality that mindset yeah I don't
think I don't think Phil changes as a
person I think they still have that
mentality still think they roll out some
services services related type things I
still think we see game pass maybe that
was ggressive on the backwards
compatibility stuff but I can't say I
see them change much because I almost
feel like like I feel like if you had at
some point what Satya took over in the
car taking Microsoft in a different
direction I do want to say that we're
talking about a Phil Spencer his head if
Don still was around then this is
completely involved yeah but you know I
just feel like he also had to maybe go
to South you kind of maybe resell why
gaming was was important to Microsoft
considering this shift Microsoft shift
now from you know going from a company
that was you know so reliant to Windows
and everything in it did like we know
now such was like look we need to be on
every platform and that's it it did seem
like in the past I would say five years
you know since the Xbox one first launch
that Microsoft went from a back thought
on gaming and the Xbox brand to like
front and center on the Xbox bran why I
think part of this part I think Phil how
to show them hey look guys like here's
other areas where we can drive revenue I
know it's not a sexy business model I
mean the console business model isn't
has never really been a and a sexy model
I mean there's it's it's you don't make
much money you know on the hardware and
you make it up on the software side of
things
no but if you're not software you're
losing money it's like I was saying you
know me when me and more Cognito and you
know King David was everywhere I can't
remember he was part of this
conversation but uh we were talking to
that uh you know the dude who one of the
lead of people who designed the elite
controller you know yeah says that that
that that reign anarchy is extremely
difficult the elite control almost got
cancelled like
idiot just to get it up the ladder do
they work for that a week came out the
struggles that he was explaining to us
during the past leadership
infrastructure really surprised us a lot
of information that he gave out to us
that day when we took the time shout out
to Lord cognitively recognizing the man
and acknowledging the man and bringing
the man to the team so we can actually
have the conversation with him and shout
out to him for being willing and open
the funny thing is that like they went
they did a complete 360 they went from
like I don't know the elites gonna be
like this to like he said he had like
remember his own supply they kept week
after it blew up and they sold out they
made that elite console and they came in
there eject all his supply real quick
before we move on lore Fonzarelli what
do you think if the role was reversed
with Microsoft still maintaining this
attitude I think so I think with every
exec they have their own plans in place
and I think to a certain extent arose
yeah I think the to a certain extent
they stick to it you know I know there's
certain things that would would Phil
Spencer that he's sort of went back on
but I think as a business you kind of
have to look at it as a business that
that day you could have to go completely
by what you say exactly and I think
that's what he's doing and that's great
that he's doing that some people are
bashing him because he's making some
changes to what he initially said but
hey that's him adapting that's him
making changes for the betterment of the
company and that is what he should do as
a businessman and I think it's gonna
benefit us as well it's gonna be
trickled down here
we're gonna feel the benefit of that I
got another question sorry no no no and
and I just think that but yes with every
company though what it would be what
will happen though is at certain points
if your way on top you can very easily
slip to the bottom next gen it happened
with a 360 in the PlayStation because
with the PlayStation you you notice last
gen with the ps3 that momentum was
shifting at the very end yes and that
happens was relaxed and and I think that
it can very easily go the other way this
next coming good point
absolutely you know what it comes down
to it you know I do want to state that
you know people say that you know
Microsoft can't close that gap because
they still lose MPD's every month but
let me tell you something right now
usually around the last two or three
years of a gin one side has already hit
its peak and it literally just starts
getting like the bare minimum every
month that's what happened to xbox 360
last year at the end of that generation
it hit its peak and they and the three
and the ps3 just started looking so much
ground so quickly look at what what
Microsoft is focusing on right now
they've got so much going for them you
know they have so many game services and
stuff that you can go with game Pass ea
access you have the backwards
compatibility and if you look over it
Sony side you have streaming online Lord
braaap had a conversation or a brat read
about this and then you hear the
PlayStation and and they've banked and
they've banked heavy on VR and let me
tell you something about VR I think that
it's fantastic that a lot of people do
like it but I think that this could very
possibly go the way of 3d glasses and
all that I mean and watching 3d movies
it's literally a rock throw like Mars
that going over the river because it's
not really I mean yes it's selling to a
certain degree but it's not taken off
it's not huge I don't think VR is gonna
be a huge thing like like some of these
people are thinking it's gonna be right
now anyway because I think right now you
you have to have space for it you have
to have all these cables like it's very
you know just it's it's not it's not
streamlined looks like let's say that
bad I do want to say something before
you say something King III I do I do
want to finish here and said that with
the VR with the VR stuff there's also a
lot of people out there like myself that
it that get motion sickness easily they
can't even use the current state of VR
so VR has a lot of hurdles to jump and I
think that's the wrong thing to be
focusing on that is why with the xbox
when I heard about them going
third-party VR beautiful fantastic let
somebody else but yeah that is the way
to do it because they don't have to
focus on that hardware they can focus on
games that is the way to do it there so
I think next-gen amen anything could
happen I think Xbox can be the leaders
next gen cuz I don't care about VR but
this is just one quick thing that you
know I didn't get a state because they
you know we can't progressively going
through the topic do you think monster I
would have come out of first mr. Dayton
takeover mmm I'm really thinking of what
I don't think real quick on the VR and
close that off I think they learn a
lesson on hololens just i think they saw
are expensive there was and how limited
that was where they decided listen let's
just a piecemeal off the VR thought to
somebody else let it mature first
because it's in its infancy
kudos to Sony for taking a step forward
and trying to help in its infancy being
out there the market leader they didn't
have to take the out step out but when
you are the market leader and when you
are leading you're able to take these
bold moves forward so hopefully they can
fix those people to get motion sickness
and stuff like that but as far as the VR
goes from that standpoint in their price
point they are aggressive
we attacking it and I I appreciate it
because once you play VR in their space
it adds an extra gun or extra bullet to
their to their gun and it's really it's
worth a try no doubt so we've all pretty
much on the same page as far as reign of
bullying and things have been coming out
between him and uh Phil Spencer in a
positive direction at Microsoft's going
in but it's also some other news going
on right Lord addict there's a possible
announcement what's what's going on
apparently uh they might be announced
Microsoft might be announcing something
here relatively soon I think they said
next week yeah
yeah I think it's a state of decay we've
released a wrapping on this because I
know he was one of the first ones to
bring it to my attention and I want to
get him let him kick this thing off so
we we we heard this from what is it
industry insider was a huge grab the
flora what what do we know so far what's
being rolled so huge in reset area the
recent era forums kind of gave a quick
broke some guy I guess kind of broke
some views with like regards to you know
what Microsoft budget but more
importantly the the big news next week
that they're going to make some
announcement regarding how they treat
digital games and so the first thing
that came to my mind
and again this is a pure speculation you
know III chat was he huge but he hasn't
like you know giving me any inside
information I was like woo they're gonna
they figured out a way to do trade-ins
and I'm like if they do that I like I
first of all I would probably never get
will depending on what the trading
values are you know like so long game so
our game stopped no and and to me if
they can do that if they figure out how
to land off and they can make it
competitive with like a Game Stop and
what best buy/offers lookout I mean talk
about having the ultimate services
platform for gamers yeah this would be
something I wanted
shout out to the inner circle podcast
last night they definitely went on this
out to cow be money you know anchor and
um they were also talking about like
what could this digital announcement be
right
so obviously I'm gonna jump in right now
by hope is digital tray about ratings
like you say I mean I think that would
be huge and then they started discussing
on you know possibly what would be the
percentage would it be like maybe 10
percent back on a game and stuff like
that so if it is did first of all morons
what do you think the digital
announcement could be and if it is
digital trade-ins what would you you
know I want it to be digital trading so
is the month yeah I want to know the
street date of state of decay to because
I'm a big fan the for yeah he was
reinstated okay and just being co-op in
the game it's really got me excited you
guys want to like legitly what it could
be
what's a family sharing that they said
they were gonna bring back that's the
other option shut up the couch how could
take they won it that was another option
but that's your your left fathers really
finish up we go get it do you know what
that it might be family sharing I think
he's right but digital trade ins would
be beautiful beautiful another one of us
both even at 10 percent back I would
take it man that that's awesome
we work out till I wasn't six bucks or
so be aggressive with it as far as if
you purchase a game and has a
stipulation on a time date or how much
it's worth from this period to that
period and in the grades after a period
of time it gets lower and lower like if
they gave you a disclosure you buy a
game that was like you can trade this
back in and I had a time chart I think
that's fine yeah yeah that's it I think
they thought about it I think that they
need this and like you said if that
happens if I got a smile on my face but
yeah from in here yeah actually they
fundamentally change how you purchase
trade and gift games because I give
games to people sometimes all right I
see somebody on my friends listen I
understand the economic situation and if
I'm in an economic situation that's a
little bit more
voracious than this I you know
facilitated games hey let's do it let's
play because I play with you I want to
play all day long I'm not gonna um you
know stop the fun fire you know for this
so if they're at a point where they say
yo
we already got game sharing then which
is insane because a lot of people don't
know about that alright so once you tell
somebody oh yeah we log in together we
[ __ ] a digital library what that's
insane
all right they got a gifting of games
that's insane
now if they say they got buybacks oh I
don't think it's my backs I feel like
everything they're doing it's pointing
to sharing okay so let's get into the
sharing thing so what do you like how
the initial vision when they first came
out you know when they got attacked kind
of like always online but you can share
digital games and there wasn't an issue
thing that they kind of like it was like
a family plan right some to that effect
yeah when you can share much so what do
you think Lord addict like what do you
think they hate how they might approach
it I don't think we'll get that because
you know a lot of people think that the
sharing you know the digital library is
hurting the industry yeah it's like
trust me if it was hurting the industry
we would know it would be gone like one
developer like if anything you know
search sure first off you don't have a
huntress think guarantee that every
second person was gonna pick up that
game anyway most of the time only big
big games we're gonna get on but it is
it is still a sale loss though if stop
has took their stock as Trembley what
down I have to say something on this
because I have some information from
Phil Spencer himself oh well here's the
thing I asked him straight up about game
sharing I said you know and he kind of
chuckled and was like Toby they asked
you did that like neck thing where you
laughs that's supposed to talk about if
we go talk about because I was asked him
straight up I was like look how do you
guys get around game sharing I mean how
do you guys feel about that because
essentially people could be game sharing
from across the the pond across the
world you know and stuff like that and
and he's like well you're not really
supposed to be doing it that way and he
broke it down how it's supposed to be
done and he was like but look he goes in
the end that helps us he says that helps
the industry that he has data to show
that game sharing is actually promoting
sales and actually if I buy a game and
we are sharing you got the next game up
and he had people that came he had some
of the studios come in because some of
them are upset about game sharing they
go in there thinking hey you know we're
losing sales and he shows them the data
and they walk out with a smile he says
it's like I said like first off they're
getting a way bigger cut digitally yeah
and you know it's like I said you know
you look at these you see that's one one
of the reasons that the you know people
want to use uh you know MBG char it's
like you can't even use that accurately
anymore right because digital is not
always because it's even on ps4 you can
share libraries in there so yeah you
went he went on to even say that he says
they know who's doing it and and doing
it correctly and they could see and they
could they could ban the the exact
person who's doing the wrong here he
says but they don't because it promotes
those sales it's it's a benefit no it's
one of those things that I was taken
aback by that he told me this stuff and
I was like wow okay that's I open
because I thought it was a sale lost
that's a good point because I even even
towards I gave you as the generation
continued to go on I remember I believe
it was I don't don't quote me it was
either say it was Heath Greenberg or
Ibarra and they actually for the first
time referenced sharing and um oh it was
almost like the unspoken thing people
knew about it Microsoft didn't go out
there out there way to promote it you
know I mean and I know it was like when
I was kind of the first mention of
sharing openly by like on Microsoft
exact your feedback what Phil is pretty
interesting lafon you can tell like I
think if anything it might not be game
sharing it might be making that backdoor
like legit legal
it's open game because because if you
look at it you have certain situations
like you know they're actually referring
to this program like it it isn't a back
door that people use and they're they're
doing stuff like increasing the amount
of times you could change home they'd
done that another three you can do it
six total now it used to be three
there's no reason to do that unless
you're on the download promoting that
service mmm-hmm what do you feel a blood
breath you know i david brought
something up earlier like it game how
game sharing promotes sales because like
you know someone buys a game and then
the other person is up next right and so
it almost forces like you to be more
like you have to might because you want
to keep that library going you want to
get behind keep that marriage
relationships that have changed over you
you understand exactly how valuable that
companion is once they leave that is the
best thing to hear the conversations
because i I game share with inside my
household alright so but to hear the
conversations with people that game
share with each other or you got this
game oh but I brought the last game but
you know how my tax situation is the
best conversations when you start
threatening I don't see efforts we've
seen a lot at Aquino of head some people
will not say any names they would come
to us and they say yo man such a such a
pulling his weight in this relationship
it's like it's like oh yeah I got a
link-up with my kids bran they don't buy
nothing but I already told ran though
Randall Thor I said Amen next when
whoever your game she leaves you or
something make sure you hit me up
because I got a random DM and it was
like um from a random person that I know
Oh take me out the dinner
I used to get them all the time but I
don't really anymore where people will
be random move like you I want such a
such game but I'll let you read you
such-and-such day what a game sure like
know what happens what this big digital
announcement from Microsoft is and will
see me hopefully all of us got our
fingers crossed we hope it is um either
an extension of game sharing or digital
trainings both would be pretty pretty
huge so we gonna move on to the final
topic and uh we got talk about some
cardboard these days Kinkos I've no clue
what the slide was but I have to go so
I'm gonna do you explain it because I
want to know what this is we all get it
we go break it here we go break it
grandfather dead oh crap on Nintendo's
really happy speech right now and
everybody thought off of their last what
was the little mini treehouse jump off
that they were going to arm they direct
that they were going to you know have a
giant direct right after that and at
least all these other games but just
when you thought mint endo was following
in step and hand in hand left happens
and I know what left happens when my
phone my Twitter just starts going right
and I'm laying there trying to get some
sleep and you know usually I hear one or
two drums and I'm like ooh no it got to
the point where I had to get up a mute
it I got up and I muted it and it said
you have 45 tweets what everybody got
these memes of cardboard the nastiest
thing that I saw was a mean where says a
Nintendo and it has a guy with the
fishing pole pulling the first pole out
only Nintendo key to this I say okay I
said all right
I gotta find out I got a do
the the due diligence here to find out
what's going on I gotta investigate this
and once they say lab oh alright first
Nintendo's the only one that can come up
with these weird names right well
everything's bonus amiibos plan they are
the only ones that are bold enough
daring enough not taking the stairs
right now this is premium cardboard the
Lord King taking your recycled trash
you probably got something from Amazon
and you out the box and Nintendo came
through they got stock piles of Amazon
trash and they sell it to you $70 a pop
and it's gonna go viral of funds explain
the Lord addict what did Tendo lab oh
it's go kid all right
my initial thoughts was the same as you
guys when I first saw the the cardboard
you know I wasn't even looking at the
software aspect or nothing I just saw
cardboard and I was thinking pizza boxes
you know to us but then I I did some
more digging cuz I didn't like all the
negativity I was hearing out there on
this stuff like I'm like what's going on
here Nintendo's gotta have a reason for
this even though sometimes Nintendo
don't have to have a reason for nothing
but I you know I said there's gotta be
something behind this so I start looking
into it and I look at this $70 kit and I
see okay it comes with a kit you you get
with this kit you get 2 RC cards cars a
fishing rod a house a motorbike and a
piano and you get all the software for
those things to you get you have these
little games and stuff you can do with
this stuff and then the other one is a
big bike robot kit you can actually put
it on your back and everything yeah and
it's got like a foot pedal and stuff
that you can actually interact with a
robot game and I was like wait you know
what games are 60 bucks a pop brand-new
you add in the cardboard yeah you know
ten bucks you know no big deal then I
was looking further into it I was like
okay so these kids they're they're like
building it they're coloring it they're
they're making it their own and I was
thinking back to when I was a child and
I was like you know what I would have
loved this as a kid I used to put things
together draw and stuff and I used to
love doing this kind of stuff and I said
so as a parent I can understand that if
my kids wanted something like this it
promotes creativity and and I'm all that
but as an adult I don't know for
anything to do it for us like this is
targeting a kid you don't know that yes
before you go like it all it is it's
kind of like do these do-it-yourself
cardboard creations way it's kind of
preset so like one might be a piano the
other ones like a motorbike the other
ones so basically you take the cardboard
you you you construct it in a preset
configuration you can't like create your
own thing they have all these different
kind of models and then what it works
with the IR blaster of the Nintendo
switch to joy Khan so that they I guess
they're gonna have software and games
like you put the little you know the
switch tablet portion in in in the front
and then you got the handlebars on a
motorbike and in the screen of the
switch
you know simulate you actually driving
the bike so this is clearly fitted we
have two point oh a lot of negativity
stems from the adults in the community
and look where are you it's not for is
not for the kids you know and it's not
back in the day when you used to build
stuff even if actually goes or you took
an old box that your mom had made a [ __ ]
out of it backs on it got pushed it on
the house or King remember loose the
bottom plane the foam plane did you put
together and put I also remember getting
a little pouch from guys it was 50
Cent's and it was 25 cents I remember
this stuff and this is an interactive
hold up and wait right now we got your
Playstation and you turned it on for the
first time and it was a deleting all
that DRM it took like 24 hours for that
to happen so this huh we give you a wait
why are you doing this it's a gonna
slaughter these big Z's going ham on
this
I just wanted adults when they get a
hold of this stuff and they start coming
up with their own concoctions to these
cardboard games you're basically paying
for all that software you're getting all
these little yes because you can play
with it without the cardboard as well
the price since that cardboard is is
that extra a bit of you know creation
and all that stuff that I think that
kids will really adapt to and it's
already the number one seller on Amazon
you know this thing is gonna be huge and
and you guys are right though like Sony
and Microsoft couldn't pull this off but
there's a reason like you don't know
caterers caters to the old and young and
very young and so then they can do this
you know what i'ma tell you this I know
that Nintendo has a whole warehouse full
of these thoughts nitendo has been the
king of recycling everything right now
they took these thoughts they took your
thoughts and he said what's the most fun
aspect of your childhood because they
delve deep inside a child's mind and
what they're doing is fostering
creativity at the fundamental level of
these children to bring them back to
gaming before king is definitely buying
this I can't buy it for my son because
my son gaming maturity level because
he's been gaming since he was 2 years
old his gaming maturity level is that of
a teenager of a 15 or 16 year old he's
seven
he's now thank you so I could see a kid
six seven years old doing this stuff and
having fun with it but like yeah the
older children ah but I'd rather give my
kid it's a six years old this lab okit
rather than giving them a Call of Duty
and having them just sit there exactly
yes my kid has been already exposed to
the call of duty so if I hand him this
cardboard box he's too late he's going
to have the same reaction that I'm
having what Nintendo was trying to do is
get these kids that have their first
experience for gaming to be a legendary
experience it's the same reason why kids
don't play outside today stuff anymore
and that's that's what I'm thinking back
like when you were children man we we
were outside all the time we had video
games but we played we did the streets
was a little bit safer though no way
I've discussed the kid is young enough
trust me if my son was at the age where
he wasn't corrupted
by because he plays The Witcher and
stuff like that
all right he learned how to read to
video games I'm not lying to you I swear
to God
oh so he's a little prodigy and it's not
just because it's my kid but he has
forced the evolution of learning through
the video games because he wanted to
keep up with his older sisters he's
knocking out every kid yes now it's a
fighter nobody beat oh no baby gets this
I gotta get you good on this man what's
your whole feeling of the Nintendo lab
oh all right so I I have a little bit of
a long take on this I'm go let's go so
this this is this is Nintendo's answer
to VR think about this right you want to
play in a robe as a robot and and and
Sony probably has a robot game for you
but you have to wherever your headset
right Nintendo you could just strap a
cardboard box to your back you know pull
a couple levers you know so this is this
is their answer and I said this to uh
this is one of my friends the other day
we were talking about a lot of things
like you actually it kind of makes sense
he's like it's it's like VR if we were
like little kids and we wanted VR like
how what were a real life and we said
Cobra boxes we always but we always took
back to Cobra boxes right but I think
this is the genius behind this is that
they're also looking to get people into
gaming don't traditionally game yes
people that play with Carrboro boxes
outside or or or have you know it's
children children you know we always
talk about the imaginations children
have and you know scoring up and
remember using our imaginations to play
out scenarios do different things you
know you playing transformers with your
friends like little girls coloring and
stuff like that they'll get Arab girls
playing video games this way yeah
audience you're right it's a different
it's not for that's a good point yeah
this is a this is a great move by
Nintendo because the tender is always
looking to figure out ways to
incorporate the non gamer how could look
we have the core gamer
how can we get other people in the
gaming and and they're the ones that
that and this is this is what they're
doing with this
I'm sorry - you said grown people who
buy an essence anus for their kids but
it's really for them oh crap good job
but it's that's the brains of this and I
think that look like I I had the same
thing like like JC like when I saw it I
was like all they're totally trolling I
was like this is just they're trolling
us are gonna drop Pokemon the RPG game
on us you know this is your remarketing
and then no this was in fact the thing
for them and I and I had a step wait a
minute
seeing this isn't for me this is for my
children my children would love this
they would absolutely love this because
it takes something they enjoy their rage
we're playing the switch now that you
get to build something get to use your
imagination and you know that's kinda
like the knock against gaming sometimes
people feel like you just sit your
accounts potato burning your brain cells
this kind of thing kid bunks that myth
of that or that stereotype that people
have of gaming and then again it
incorporates those non-gamers those kids
who maybe wouldn't touch a video game
now now maybe they have a reason to now
and and I think this thing like be money
said it's like the number one seller on
Amazon now I didn't already have legs I
think I think Nintendo is just firing
all cylinders in and I think you said it
earlier Cognito they're the only ones
that can get away with this absolutely
taking game you're getting one mad cuz
it's premium cardboard you can catch me
with that but she's not catching with
this karpova i'ma tell you if you know
what let me stop right here because they
will come out with a kid that will talk
to me mm-hmm the VR you don't remember
it was like an article that came out I
think was on reddit or something like
that it was not too long ago and he
talked about Nintendo was talking about
cardboard VR and people were like what
but it was cardboard VR that's out here
that people just do the cardboard and
you slip your phone inside a baby
right so they was talking about Nintendo
boy now that's the first time I heard
Nintendo record boy maybe you put the
switch in and they already had a thing
in place does this facilitate does the
self of this right here where they go
straight for the child gamer here and
then they go for us with the VR with the
cardboard for the adults listen I think
is what I think more Bram just nailed it
I think it's one of those things that
you trying to get that market they're
trying to get that market that wouldn't
normally not you know buy video games
like that and you know speaking of
Lawrence's point with just a creativity
and just as simple as simple is like
Lego blocks and all those creative
things that you know kids are not doing
and I'm telling ya I have a funny
feeling of this thing's gonna take off
you got Michael monkey punch in the chat
he said just so software and gives your
own box he's not off base because I read
a story today Nintendo was gonna sell
templates for that to do just that to
your own cardboard out if you'd like
well I will say this to low phones I
mean one thing I do appreciate as much
as week we kind of clown in a little bit
is that for like you know the kids that
you know it might not come from you know
well-established financial situations at
home and you can kind of make something
out of that if that's the case by
naturally that is a serious dollar that
you just talking about listen to this
the system's 300 that's seventy you get
two of them you are at four hundred and
forty bucks you're talking premium here
okay this child the child first of all
who's given a three or four yo switch
like what is going on in Tendo give me a
price cut you just switch play with that
cardboard
it's al-faisal stones but how many
broken switches is in the process of
Nintendo thought about the 4-sided they
say you know we don't really have a
protection plan on a switch he said true
let's make the cardboard for the kids to
break it more broken switches don't be
in the streets that's the question is
this something that's gonna pop for
Nintendo what you what should you take
okay yeah I think it's gonna sell it's
already the number one seller on Amazon
is all this this Christmas it's gonna
sell I think it's gonna be a big thing
for them and they're they're probably
gonna make more of this stuff more kids
I think Nintendo doubles their sales on
switches which is law brat what do you
think Hank after the jokes does this
thing sell does the lab we'll take off I
absolutely think it takes off we're
seeing it on Amazon and I I'll say it
again this thing is look the fact that
we're talking about it okay the fact
that we're like oh my god it's cardboard
they're excited that we're talking about
it kids are loving the level idea I
showed my nine-year-old daughter that
one of the kids and she thought it was
awesome she was like that was cool we
don't have a switch so I can't get it
but if I did have a switch I died by
four with the piano key one the piano
one yeah dad
yeah the tech behind the the joy car can
detect which keys you're hitting that's
a member when people want to know what
the deal was with that IR blaster yes to
me this is another functionality we have
to give the tech of the switch credit
we're lucky and now lab oh this is a big
deal of how to utilize an extra
functionality and I remember be money
was like talking because we like I would
we're talking like the when the switch
first came out I was like be why these
why are these joy Khan so expensive
because I can say it's the technology
behind it and he's like you you watch
you goes attenders about to change the
game when it comes to controllers and I
didn't believe them here we are and be
Maitreya yeah Nintendo has made their
bones on their controllers and this
controller once I saw that you can feel
like like it when they had to do the
shaky thing and it felt like it was Isis
on my cup like when you do the last Wow
these controllers are actually more than
what they're marketing over there
knowing everyone very very great people
out of people don't give those joy
Khan's a lot of credit I mean it's so
much they can giving just looking I know
you know like just when you do
multiplayer and you detach both and you
give someone you know one individually
and all the things you can see it can
it's pretty impressive strolling a
Microsoft is already down a path where
these controllers are probably their DNA
and that's it Nintendo separated the DNA
and made the software their DNA and
everything else is a new experience
every system is a new experience how
much you want to bet somebody's gonna 3d
plastic they're gonna double the sales
of the switch this year guarantee all
four broken switches alone stickers oh
yeah you know Pokemon decaf everyone's
on the cardboard era level we gotta
finish the survey - Allatoona frogs guys
are coming through but we gotta close up
with the poll
so we got a new ILP poll this week so
with all the recent announcements and
rumors and Xbox you know booty has VP
the recommitment the first IP you know
all these League games were hearing
about digital gaming rumors how excited
are we regarding the future of the Xbox
brand so questions aren't choices are a
very excited the future looks bright be
Sony is still too way ahead too little
too late or see we don't care cuz
Lambeau was gonna outsell a ball when it
goes up Lord Fonzarelli thank you so
much for coming through everything you
do all the podcast you know I'm an
absolute pleasure where can the fine
people find you oh man they can find me
pretty much everywhere right I mean they
can find me at Jay Fonzarelli on YouTube
and Twitter that's two r's 2 l's and
then i and they can find me at loot
chests radio on twitter and youtube as
well and you can find me on the g RG
podcast Tuesdays at 8 p.m. Eastern Time
on dealer gaming's channel Oh
shall the Lord do and you can find me on
the TSP podcast as well Oh Sunday nights
South Aloha salt that's again at 8 p.m.
Eastern Time on saltiest gaming's
channel also on g RG podcast when I can
make it I'm over there Friday nights at
6 is your business let's go and of
course that's on K mega channel at 9
p.m. Eastern Time Takei Mecca and then
over on the 60 frames know like podcast
on Wednesdays at 5 p.m. Eastern Time
with Porter rocks have no doubt the
local auto ride we've been trying we
made him and we've gone back as well we
get him on a show - absolutely
hardest-working man in show biz law
finals are really always appreciate us
active huge fan of what you do one of
the positive beacons in the community
and truly balance makes us all think out
there it's long overdue for you to be in
the realm of the Lord's absolute
pleasure I appreciate it man
it's been you already know then Lord
wrapped with the carry o today really
appreciate you come through helping us
out during the booty era mob rep banner
always a pleasure which rants and
everything that's going on at the
basement radio arcade podcast when
people find you tell us what's going on
yep you guys everyone can find me on
twitter at ab rap underscore podcast and
you can find me on a rap on youtube the
basement radio k podcast wednesday
nights at 9:00 p.m. Eastern Standard
Time it's myself the money Eric Jackson
mr. negative when he can make it and we
always have a variety of community guest
on J Fonzarelli has been on we've had
the iron Lords on so yeah definitely
definitely I'm sorry coming through
again yeah gotta get Lord King back on
one song you gotta come on man it's been
it's been too long man it's been - yeah
listen I got some stuff in the mix me
you gonna talk after this about that
because we you and it's going to be a
conglomerate sorry girl okay you can
also find me on a loot chests radio with
really all they digital definitely check
us out
I love the production values you do Jeff
yeah what are your cues that awesome I
just love to call and act like I'm
calling 65 and y'all only something next
time you call in i'll say the shirts in
the mail or very unique concept
please lords like if you guys you know
call in these guys really entertain all
questions you know and it's a really
cool
radio 5
speaking of calling in this week's
voicemail
man is lit another mike rizzo has a fan
let's just say I have a fan you guys
check that out
it's Luke the law gave me a terrific
coming through I know he had his busy
schedule but he stopped in the young
wolf you know I'm saying and law solve
we miss you man hopefully we get you
there the noses of the fish absolutely
absolutely King the premium gaming with
that premium cardboard today listen
shout out to Jay phones really um I want
to tell you because you know you made a
statement earlier about you put 14 hours
in and you had a hundred views or
whatever and I'm one of those hundred um
I appreciate everything that you do I
look at you and X bots and the
production value that you guys and the
hard work I see and you know it gives me
something to aspire to
when I start to take those steps out
because you know you look at other
people's stuff and they like you said
these guys are getting their views and
stuff but yes stuff is quality so I
rather take quality over quantity any
day good point girl came because what we
want to let you know too is that yeah
maybe not getting a success that we feel
you deserve but it resonates with real
gamers and that's what it that's what it
is you know expired also I want to give
a shout out to our shouting them out
before to go east woods another oh yeah
we see the effort you guys put in and
you know it we gotta spread love to
these guys these guys in the community
that's really doing anything and on we
gotta promote that positivity man a lot
of people are hitting a good work happy
for the first big card of the year we
had you on the next day we a little bit
unconventional we're gonna talk to that
game and talk but we're also gonna talk
that ballroom talk that we always talk
exam anytime you guys want to talk
combat sports a feel free to invite much
you know what low funds in this light
tell you like you inspired us because
they were all we were getting pushed
back to even not even include that and
this is something that we you and then
when we seen guys like you and a couple
other laws like yo we love when your
tour car better it kind of gave us the
confidence to even still included keep
going about what's going on so again
each one teach one you guys helped us
here we spread the gaming realness today
on ILP thanks everyone in the chat for
coming through everything was pretty
much lit make sure you hit like
subscribe and all the ILP and all the
inner circle Network media outlets we
got the multiverse up tomorrow with Lord
anchorman please subscribe to them and
I'll get the audio out to you guys
tonight man all the support all the
stuff really helps me really appreciate
you guys and love that you guys come
through and show love to ILP so when
everybody to enjoy their Sunday I know
you guys got football and deca to your
families and just earth we'll see you on
the next one peace peace